that's amazing grape now see it in a
different time
grape
[Music]
and now look that way just look forward
Steve that doesn't look like me [__] you
guys it wasn't us there was a JK fans
that said that I mean I get it because
like yeah the hairline's pretty funny
yeah JK and it's white [__] said this
a white guy it's a smirk Jacob sent this
and then another person was like yeah
this guy looks like he [__] hates
kendras that's what they said
a broken watch is right twice a day he's
like prematurely
he's diet Steve Green I have thin lips I
get it Great Value so this guy
is a he's a Dollar Tree Steve yeah a
foreign
a former Virginia police officer
believed to have murdered a teenager's
family in Riverside California
after catfishing her online what he was
recently killed in a shootout while
trying to flee authorities okay and not
only did this guy murder you know the
teenager he murdered her parents as well
why damn that's crazy so he catfished
them just to kill him he catfished
because he's trying to get because he's
a pedal I believe I believe that the
teenager was 15 and he pretended to be a
17 year old boy
catfished ooh whack so uh xcop was
identified as Austin Lee Edwards age 28
of North Chesterfield Virginia dude is
28 . he looks 65 dude [__] 40. I
thought it was 40 something yeah he
looks so this guy is 28. he looks weird
he's seen some [__] I thought he was 37.
if I get defensive yeah I thought he
would play defensive this whole time
yeah he looked um you know it's not
always about the looks he looked like
you know like a good guy it could have
been a good guy you never know anybody's
story there's only two sides we don't
know what big the movie is come on guys
empathy empathy why was he a former cop
oh did he get kicked out they're like we
don't want pedophiles on this unit I
like the idea of Defending someone just
because they look like you this guy's
not that bad come on think about it I
think I would be a little higher than
this guy
you guys made that the first unusual
thing I'm just going with it
detective said they believe Edwards had
met the team through catfishing a form
of online deception in which someone
pretends to be a different person
officers with the Riverside Police were
dispatched Friday to check the welfare
of a young female who appeared
distressed while getting into a red car
with a man who looks like Steve police
said while officers were responding
a copy off guard dude sounds good you
said it's so dead pan bro sometimes you
try to you know
sometimes and you don't do it okay this
was good that was a good old Steve David
that was good while officers were
responding 9 11 dispatchers began
getting calls about a fire in the same
neighborhood just a few houses away from
where the welfare our check originated
firefighters discovered three adult
victims lying in the front entryway of
the burning home when they pulled them
outside it was determined they were the
victims of an apparent homicide wow a
preliminary investigation determined the
young female described in the initial
call was a teenager who lived with a
house fire and homicides occurred so
that's how it was connected basically as
police were responding to this you know
like oh some chick got into a car in a
weird way the same time as they went to
go investigate it [__] firefighters
were finding this burnt family and it
was that dude so the the chick got in
first went to the house murder happened
and then he burnt that and he burned the
house down dude it's this is super sad
but also at the same time
Howard how is someone that young falling
for catfishing I thought that's like old
people [__] fall for that oh [__]
aren't young people more versed about
like figuring out wasn't two of like
early 20s who you remember two of the
the San Diego Charger like but in
college he like fell for a catfishing
scam like that big time my tattoo right
oh you're talking about Manti oh Manta
tail [__] that's it too yeah my bad whoa
I feel like a lot of that but that was a
long that was a long time I heard the
tea I feel like a lot of people still
get catfish though but then like we got
so much [__] examples like we got TV
show called Catfish that teaches you all
about how to verify yeah but 15. just
have a video chat with someone before
you meet them yeah it's a vulnerable age
especially at the age where you're like
you want to meet somebody and you're
like he probably knows how to play her
[__] heart but that's like I always I
just I don't know I assume the younger
people were more Savvy about what's the
Netflix documentary about what Jaya went
through [__] crazy and that voice is
so [__] good we should talk about
that's really good but it's an amazing
it still had all I mean he was pretty
vulnerable emotionally
she was the [__] Oscar she she feel
free to catch up the rest of the class
well it's all about the mark right I
don't want to spoil it though because
that's a good it's a really good
document oh okay spoiler alerts go ahead
well no like this is one of the this is
one of the most nationally like like
known about Catfish story yeah I know
that because he basically was a college
football star and then he had a
girlfriend and like she had like prob
like medical issues and he was like
helping to raise funds for her but it
was all a catfish all of it the story
the whole time and he never met her and
so the girlfriend he was doing it for
it's crazy yeah yeah yeah and then um
and did they find a catfish well then
they find out that she's a catfish and
then he's humiliated he still actually
makes it to an NFL team the Chargers
draft him he actually has an okay career
it's like not terrible what's up nice
for him yeah but like [__] He's
humiliated yeah that's staying out
because they're like this guy's it
didn't need to happen yeah yeah and then
they were all calling him gay and [__]
yeah exactly yeah yeah it was like a way
really unnecessary people like me are
calling him gay online and then you saw
[Laughter]
high level highest level but still one
video chat would have fixed that entire
thing yeah exactly that's what's so
mind-blowing but the excuses these guys
make they're such good gaslighters and
like like manipulators like it's wild
yeah so so you have to think about now
turn all that ammo on a 15 year old girl
it's like that changes the whole
conversation think about Manchester dude
if he was like if he wasn't such a good
boy if he was such a good Christian boy
and if he went out to parties and
started banging chicks like a normal
college football player yeah he would
have never been in this situation yeah
for sure treat smart exactly exactly
yeah yeah yeah yeah
bang them hoes break them back yeah it
is what like 17 18. Crazy according to
police Edwards had developed an online
relationship with the teen and obtained
her personal information he then
traveled from Virginia to Riverside
where he parked his vehicle in a
neighbor's driveway and walked to the
teen's home at some point authorities
believe Edwards murdered the teen's
grandfather grandmother and mother
before walking back to his vehicle with
the teen and leaving whoa so she
witnessed that maybe maybe several hours
after the bodies were found Edwards was
spotted driving with the teen through
San Bernardino County according to the
release Edwards exchanged gunfire with
the San Bernardino County sheriff's
deputies attempting to stop him was shot
by deputies and was later pronounced
dead at the scene actually the teen
survived the teen was unharmed and later
placed into protective custody of the
Riverside County department can you
imagine that so she wasn't great or
nothing that the word great has nothing
to do with it maybe because when they
say because when they say unharmed that
means unmolested oh that's true you're
right you're right it's it's a different
feeling when you're like eating a bunch
of pistachios all nonchalant I thought
they meant unharmed because there was a
shooting that went back and forth yeah
I'm just trying to confirm you know you
thought Austin was a multitasker he
could shoot at the same time I want to
clarify what you thought they catch
somebody from a kidnapping and then they
say
the victim was found unharmed usually
means they weren't diddled I don't think
so she wanted great after nothing but
honestly when Joe says that he said it
was such a certainty I was like yeah
you're absolutely right 100 right like
the confidence of which I also want to
believe that yeah I do like don't we all
yeah
it's a good point it was like like so
yeah you can't multitask can't shoot a
grade at the same time like that's
awesome the events sound very
consecutive
I know that's an uneven thing it's like
he died but then three people you know
and then and burned the house down is it
better that she's alive because now
she's tormented with this [__]
torture with no family and think about
the guilt she must feel as a 15 year old
dude like oh what do you think that
grandma said to him she's like you look
like Beastie Green Look At Me
cops thought it was you holy [__] that's
Steve Grace that's the cryptocore guy
that's my least favorite JK tube
JK let's shoot the kill on son
we got Steve Green in a red Toyota we
got Steve oh wait I thought he doesn't
have a car
is that the woo guy he's not wearing a
jumpsuit what the [__]
oh imagine she's expecting to see some
[__] 17 year old he rolls up and she
goes Steve Green he's like God damn it
I'm not Steve Green
house
damn it
the information of the article you
started it Buckhead how did the article
open right up there get up right there
with it yeah get right up there no
touching my computer
I like the idea that the term catfish is
replaced by Steve Green
did you get Steve Green recently might
as well embrace it
got green that's what you guys want
that's what you guys get
[Music]